[Música]
que el mundo vamos a dejar a nuestros
hijos es una pregunta que nos hemos
hecho quizás muchas veces que el mundo
vamos a dejar y la respuesta es difícil
después de haber vivido la pandemia
viendo las condiciones en las que nos
encontramos
hace pocos años un grupo de científicos
publicaba un estudio que ha tenido mucha
influencia en todo el mundo en el se
planteaba que el planeta tiene nueve
límites de los cuales hemos sobrepasado
cuatro y en los otros cinco estamos en
camino de hacerlo
nos preocupa el calentamiento global y
que sigue en el planeta
pero también es verdad que en estos
últimos años se han hecho el mayor
número de esfuerzos para cuidar el
planeta
en california por ejemplo para el año
2035 tendremos ya totalmente vehículos
eléctricos
disposiciones internacionales en otras
partes del mundo nos hacen entender que
estamos en el momento de mayor cuidado
del planeta a qué se van a dedicar
nuestros hijos
estamos atravesando la cuarta revolución
industrial muchos trabajos para los
cuales estamos preparados para los que
nos hemos educado van a desaparecer pero
también es cierto que están surgiendo
otros y mejores trabajos mejor
remunerados
se trata pues de un mundo paradójico
mientras hay cosas que nos hacen ver el
futuro con pesimismo nos hacen verlo con
desconfianza hay muchos otros elementos
que nos hacen ver un futuro mejor nos
hacen ver lo optimista estamos pues
frente a un mundo paradójico por eso la
pregunta correcta no es que el mundo
vamos a dejar a nuestros hijos sino que
hijos vamos a dejar al mundo ellos serán
los que cambiarán el futuro los que
darán la esperanza para tener mejores
condiciones hacia adelante de nosotros
depende específicamente educarlos
formarlos
la solución está en enfocarnos en la
persona en nuestros hijos y no tanto en
las condiciones del sistema hacia futuro
el reto que tenemos enfrente es muy
grande el año pasado se publicó en
francia el libro titulado la fábrica de
cretinos digitales de michelle des
murguet
neurocientífico que con estudios en
francia finlandia eeuu y otras partes
del mundo
confirman que esta generación de niños
va a ser la primera menos inteligente
que la de sus padres
contrario a lo que había venido pasando
desde la segunda guerra mundial en la
que cada década crecía el coeficiente
intelectual tres puntos ahora en esta
generación desciende siete puntos la
caída es muy grande y los motivos tienen
que ver con nuestro estilo de vida con
el modo en el cual hemos hecho el
ambiente alrededor de los niños las
causas de la caída del coeficiente
intelectual son variadas una central es
el uso excesivo de dispositivos
digitales a nivel global las
estadísticas son impresionantes a los 2
años los niños ya están 4 horas frente a
una pantalla a los 7 años
prácticamente 7 horas frente a la
pantalla y en la adolescencia 89 horas
seguidas y continuas está demostrado que
estar permanentemente frente a una
pantalla disminuye la capacidad de
reflexión disminuye también la memoria
episódica
y pierde la capacidad de atención se
disminuye la capacidad de atención de
forma importante por ello distintos
gobiernos del mundo han estado
preocupados por el tema por ejemplo en
el caso de china para los videojuegos en
línea con diferentes usuarios ha
limitado el uso a tres horas a la semana
una hora los viernes en horario de 7 8
de la noche sábados y domingos también
algunos días festivos
por otra parte ha habido también una
caída en el lenguaje de los niños cada
vez se utilizan menos palabras en
distintos estudios en países de américa
latina siendo el castellano un idioma
con miles de palabras se utilizan menos
de 300 hay que recordar que las palabras
es el modo en que se expresan las ideas
y también del modo en que nosotros
reconocemos las ideas a menor número de
palabras cae en la capacidad de
pensamiento a menor número de palabras
cae la capacidad de reflexión
en esta generación ya no solamente es un
menor uso de palabras sino que los niños
ahora se expresan mucho a través de
imágenes de maurice en los cuales ya no
solamente no existe la idea sino que ni
siquiera estamos cerca de construirla
ese es el mundo que tenemos hoy un mundo
de niños que requieren entre otras cosas
un mejor sistema educativo una mejor
educación
y es en donde tenemos que apostar por
eso a todos nos queda claro que la
apuesta es la educación
pero de qué educación estamos hablando
durante muchos años en américa latina'
confundimos la educación con transmisión
del conocimiento
dejamos de lado otros elementos
fundamentales como son las competencias
o soft skills como es la inteligencia
emocional como es la cosmovisión por eso
una verdadera educación es como una mesa
de cuatro patas
si una de esas patas falta la mesa se
cae si una de esas patas es más grande
que las otras la mesa nos sirve para
sostener cosas para su propósito porque
las cosas se caen de la mesa
muchos años hemos insistido en el
conocimiento pero nos ha faltado ver los
otros elementos del desarrollo de la
persona los conocimientos si son muy
importantes son la primera pata en esa
pata tendríamos no solamente que poner
los datos de memoria en esta pata
tendríamos también que incluir la lógica
tendríamos que incluir una verdadera
comprensión de las ideas una segunda
pata son las competencias o soft skills
las que permiten a los niños resolver
problemas de nada sirven los
conocimientos y esos conocimientos no se
ponen en práctica si esos conocimientos
no significan algo en la vida de cada
niño de cada joven
en el caso de los jóvenes por ejemplo si
los conocimientos que reciben no sirven
para que cuando lleguen a un primer
trabajo resuelvan un problema esos
conocimientos realmente no están
haciendo su función
una tercera pata es de inteligencia
emocional hoy en el mundo tenemos una
crisis muy importante de depresión y de
ansiedad hay que formar la inteligencia
emocional como nos comprendemos a
nosotros mismos y como comprendemos a
los demás esta parte no la veíamos hace
años en la educación y fue hasta hace
algunas décadas con la que el libro de
la inteligencia emocional tan importante
de daniel goleman donde fuimos
conscientes de la existencia del ecu
el eco que también está muy bajo en este
momento y que en muchas ocasiones es más
importante el que el ico el coeficiente
emocional el coeficiente intelectual y
finalmente tenemos una pata que es
fundamental para entender el mundo para
poder hacer proyectos de vida para poder
conseguir una vida lograda que es la
cosmovisión los valores la ética
estas cuatro patas son fundamentales
desarrollarlas y hoy en plena
pospandemia estamos en el mejor momento
para revisar el modelo educativo estamos
en el mejor momento para ver qué hijos
hacen falta para que este mundo sea
mejor las próximas décadas por eso hoy
tenemos que preguntarnos qué hijos vamos
a dejar al mundo
qué hijos vamos a dejar desde el punto
de vista de los conocimientos que sepan
las herramientas básicas que se
requieren en la cuarta revolución
industrial
que hijos vamos a dejar desde el punto
de vista de las competencias como
resolverán problemas como harán para
enfrentarse al trabajo a la presión a
las decisiones
qué hijos vamos a dejar emocionalmente
hablando
qué hijos vamos a dejar con qué
esperanza de futuro
qué hijos vamos a dejar con cara a la
visión que requiere el mundo y la
fortaleza mental para reconstruirlo
y qué hijos vamos a dejar con qué
cosmovisión con que en sentido ético de
la vida que esperamos de su
comportamiento en los próximos años es
un buen momento para volver a revisar
las cuatro patas de la mesa es un gran
momento la post pandemia para volver a
pensar en esto para replantear qué hijos
vamos a dejar al mundo
hay que recordarlo estamos viviendo una
de las generaciones de mayor
responsabilidad histórica estamos frente
a una encrucijada
de lo que hagamos con los niños de hoy
dependerá el futuro de las siguientes
generaciones las siguientes décadas y
probablemente los próximos siglos
somos una de las generaciones de mayor
responsabilidad histórica
porque el mundo está requerido de forma
urgente de nuevas generaciones formadas
con las cuatro patas de la mesa
tenemos también la idea de este modelo
educativo no teníamos conciencia de él
hace años a través de nuestros hijos es
como podremos cambiar el futuro es como
podremos garantizar un mundo mejor un
mundo que pueda superar los riesgos que
tiene hoy el planeta a través de
nuestros hijos con ese sistema educativo
a través de nuestros hijos y como los
estemos viendo cómo estás viendo tú a
tus hijos
cómo estás esperando que sean en un
futuro hay una frase de goethe que dice
trata un ser humano como es y seguirá
siendo lo que es pero trata lo cómo
podría llegar a ser y llegará a ser
aquello que está llamado a hacer
precisamente allí es donde tendremos
mejores seres humanos mejores hijos un
mejor mundo un mejor futuro
[Música]
[Aplausos]